foreign
[Music]
hi everyone my name is Liz roten and
today I'm going to talk to you about how
you can take the project that you really
hate and turn it into something oddly
satisfying
so this adventure starts with a truck
or rather a truck Corridor study hey
there we go
my manager pitched this project to me as
a straightforward quick data science win
the only thing we needed to do was
update the data
all of the methods and
extra analysis were settled it was going
to be very easy
and it wasn't
and my first inkling of this was when I
started to look into the project
materials
they were bad they were pretty bad
and how bad are we talking here
so on the left you can see a bunch of
files and the font is way too small
because there are simply too many
and there are a couple of things I want
to point out
so there are multiple final reports
and the problem when you have something
and you name it and you have multiple
things and you name all of them final
the word final stops meaning anything
there's no telling what actually truly
is the final document
there are also multiple documents that
were marked as revised
great Marx is revised and marked revised
maybe August 11th or August 14th however
when this project first took place it
took place over more than one year so
was it August 2017 or 2018.
I don't have any information from that
and I don't know who modified it or
revised it
when they revised it or why it was
revised
and there is a single Excel workbook
with all the analysis including a
worksheet with over fifteen thousand
rows and a whole bunch of nasty formulas
that will make your skin crawl
and so now that I've introduced you to
this mess I like to Pivot to something a
little better
and it's this internet phenomenon of
things that are oddly satisfying
so oddly satisfying things is a content
of a genre of content and it's generally
something like someone taking something
super dirty and making it pristinely
clean or painting something very
precisely
I in my opinion find this tiny crab
holding up a tiny fish very satisfying
with the composition you have the yellow
and the blue and the foreground of the
background you know I think it's
satisfying but in case that doesn't
really do it for you I have a couple
more
so this first video is of a person with
a smoothie they add this purple powder
into the smoothie and you see the color
come in to the Smoothie as it's like
smoothing around and it's very
mesmerizing
and lovely
and I have one more
and that's of a person using
a turntable to ice a tart so you see the
little tart you see the turntable
turning and a person using a Piping Bag
to pipe this perfect spiral
and then once the spiral is complete
they grab a blow torch get a little
color on there
and finally they pan over to all of the
other absolutely beautiful identical
tarts
and there's something about these videos
that just soothes my soul
and so I had this moment of what if I
take the truck study and make it this
satisfying
I essentially decided to take my truck
that made me very sad
and turn it into the best truck that has
ever existed
and I learned a few things along the way
that I like to share with you
and they come in three
first
assess the damage
second do and document
and finally leave a gift
so let's assess the damage
you're essentially going to complete a
project intake
start by reading through everything and
I mean actually everything
the more you read through now the fewer
surprises you're going to have later on
and the better feel you're going to have
for the project itself
as you're doing this you're going to
make a hate list
which is a list of all of the things
about this project that you hate
maybe the documentation is vague maybe
the documentation and the calculation
aren't doing the same thing that they
should be doing
whatever it is write it down and put it
aside for later
you're also going to replicate your
findings or the results from the
previous study if applicable
and this is going to test your knowledge
of this project and it's going to give
you an opportunity to work through it
Hands-On
and even if the numbers don't align
exactly you need to be able to explain
why they don't align exactly was it a
rounding issue or a data source issue
whatever it is you just need to explain
it
and the most important part of your
intake
is finding your thing
and your thing is this one aspect or
multiple of your professional life that
makes you excited
something that you know you can work on
and you can be proud of
and you're going to find a way to apply
your thing to this project
maybe you're really into plots you're
going to go out and find all of the
ggplot2 extensions and make beautiful
plots
or perhaps you're into Maps you're going
to make some maps with some excellent
Legend work and it'll all look wonderful
or maybe you're into speed and
efficiency break out all of your
vector-based programming skills and make
this thing lightning fast
whatever it is
it's important that it's yours and it's
an important it's important that you get
excited about doing it
your thing is what's going to power this
project and
it will also keep you sane
and my thing is documentation
if you're ever unsure of what your thing
could be with a project
try documentation
and that leads us to the second part to
do and document
so you're going to do the thing complete
the work and you're going to document
along the way
there is one sentence that I think
encapsulates why documentation is so
important better than anything else
and that is this quote that
documentation is a love letter to your
future self
and this is the attitude you want to go
into documentation with
and there are folks across this
conference that will preach to you the
gospel of documentation
but there are a couple things I would
like to add in
one of them is to modularize which we
did hear about a bit this morning in the
Keynote
um so like this beautiful tart
there
every slice can be divided up equally
and b stand on its own
and you want to treat your code like
this
generally how do you know if you need to
modularize your code
if you have a single script with more
than 500 lines
too long you should consider
modularization if you're doing more than
two Scrolls
it's not going to be sustainable
so on the left there is some code that
does some spatial processing and
will take a while to run it also depends
on loading in a bunch of data sets and
having libraries in your environment and
that's fine it'll run and the script is
going to take a long time
but
if you modularize you can go into a few
different you can create scripts that
are named according to what they do
so load packages does nothing but load
packages for a solid 15 lines
load data
only loads the data it doesn't do any
extra modeling or spatial processing it
just loads the data and they don't have
to be completely independent if they
need to run sequentially you can name
them one two three
and that gives you a signal that they
need to be run sequentially
I'd also like to advocate for a bespoke
readme or a very fancy readme
a readme is an explanatory document that
accompanies computer files or software
according to Wikipedia
and I think it gets overlooked in data
science in from my observation
there are three parts of a readme that
make it truly bespoke and fancy
context
structure
and key information
so your context should answer the
questions what even is this thing
why does this thing exist and what is
its history
answer these questions in the beginning
of your readme and it'll ground this
project in what the truth and the true
meaning of why you're even working on
this
the second is structure
how is everything organized where does
the data live where do you actually do
the thing to run the analysis and get
the output
and this will also force you to take a
step back from your code and think about
it in a more structural manner
and finally key information
this is where you break out the hate
list and you're going to do the exact
opposite of the hate list you're going
to turn it into a love list
and your key information should answer
the question of
at the most fundamental level what is
the operative component and how is it
done
so with the truck Corridor study it
it was a weighted mean
which wasn't Apparent from the beginning
and so instead of leaving it a mystery I
added it in a snippet of code that
doesn't by itself run but it gives what
is the most important information
and that's my next and final part
is to leave a gift not a mystery
I have one more video for you
this is of a person
loading
a person using a
um
gift wrapping a gift with very precise
clean lines and they add a little bit of
nature at the end and it is presented on
a linen tablecloth with candles and pine
cones and
I would be utterly delighted to find a
gift like that and this is what the
energy you want to bring in to your
project debrief
the first thing to do is to take a break
once the project is done really truly
actually done
shut it
put it away and don't look at it for at
least two three weeks
and then you're going to come back in
and condense and clarify
so as I was working through the truck
Corridor study I made something like
nine hour markdowns and most of them did
not go anywhere either they were a dead
end or some exploratory analysis or they
were worked into some other part of the
analysis
but you wouldn't know that just from
looking at these files
and if you were going to work on this
project you would have to read through
all of these
so instead I broke it down into three
our markdowns I read me a bespoke read
me
a summary and methods
and
it's much more clear and concise and we
have a couple aspects that are inside
those markdowns
in the markdowns I've documented not
only what
but why
so what we used 2019 traffic data that
could be a full sentence
but if I'm looking at this in the future
and I see that this project was taking
place in 2021 and they'd already
released the 2020 data why in the world
would they use 2019
and it's likely obvious to most of us
that
2020 was quite anomalous which is why we
use the 2020 data
it was quite anomalous also known as a
garbage fire
additionally we set all of the corridors
were given scores and those scores were
broken into tiers
and we set the tier breaks at 15.4 and
26.2 points
they're very specific and it was
important it's not 15.5 it's 15.4
and not 26.2 or 30.
it's exactly 26.2
why would
we because our transportation planners
used their best judgment given a wide
array of factors outside of just these
numbers
I also really advocate for
reproducibility
you want to record package versions and
there are lots of ways that you can do
this including tools like groundhog pack
or RM
take your pick just be consistent
I'm also a big fan of a good time
stamped output you can integrate a
timestamp into the name of the file that
you're outputting or you can implement
it in like a column in a data frame
whatever you do
you need to have a year month
and day
all three
so this project is done for me for now
and I would love to tell you about how I
came to love trucks and see their
importance in the Twin Cities region and
how they're perfect for our future
economic opportunities but
still don't care about trucks
they're they're just not my thing
but every single person in my office
knows about the documentation I made for
this project
and I am so proud of the work I did
about something I don't care about
and so at the end of it I'm feeling less
like oh I don't care about this I feel a
lot like this little crab
but instead of a fish I'm holding up a
truck
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]